REMAIN FREE, AND UNABLE TO LOCK
THE DOORS.
OBVIOUSLY WE WILL KEEP YOU
UPDATED ON HOW THAT GOES.
THE POLICE AND NEW JERSEY
CLEARLY DON’T WANT TO BUT THEY
ARE BEING FORCED TO HARASS
PEOPLE WORKING OUT IN THE GYM,
HANDCUFFED THEM, THREATENING
THEM WITH JAIL.
FAR LESS ATTENTION HAS BEEN PAID
TO THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE ACTUALLY
DIED FROM THE CORONAVIRUS
BECAUSE THEY WERE VULNERABLE.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS DONE SO
LITTLE AND PLAYING DOUBLES
TENNIS OR SWIMMING.
IN PENNSYLVANIA AND NEW YORK,
POSSIBLY OTHER STATES, NURSING
HOMES WERE TOLD THEY WERE
REQUIRED TO ADMIT PATIENTS
INFECTED WITH THE CORONAVIRUS.
OUT BREAKS INEVITABLY RESULTED
THOUSANDS DIED.
LEADERS DIDN’T CARE.
IN PENNSYLVANIA, AND PERHAPS THE
MOST SHOCKING AND OFFENSIVE
EXAMPLE OF ALL ILLUSTRATING JUST
HOW LITTLE GOVERNMENT CARES
ABOUT YOU.
THE HEALTH COMMISSIONER OF THE
COMMONWEALTH, RACHEL LEVINE
MOVED HER OWN MOTHER OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL BEFORE SHE COULD FALL
VICTIM TO THE RESULTING DEATH
TRAP.
A PENNSYLVANIA STATE SENATOR, HE
WATCHED THIS WITH HIS JAW OPEN A
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
AS MANY TIMES AS WE TELL THE
STORY, IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT IT IS TRUE, YOUR STATE
HEALTH DIRECTOR MOVED HER OWN
MOTHER OUT OF THEIR NURSING HOME
AND FORCE NURSING HOMES TO ADMIT
INFECTED PATIENTS BUT THAT IS
TRUE, IS IT NOT?
>> IT IS AND YOU CAN’T MAKE THIS
STUFF UP SO LAST MONDAY NIGHT I
CALLED FOR THE RESIDENT --
RESIGNATION BUT THE
SECRETARY WITH THIS SHENANIGANS
OF THE SECRETARIES OWN MOM MOM
EVACUATING SAFE, SECURE
LOCATION.
SO WHAT ABOUT THE REST OF THE
PARENTS, GRANDPARENTS, AUNTS AND
UNCLES.
THIS SORT OF THING YOU NEVER MET
HIM WOULD HAVE BEEN IN AMERICA
ESPECIALLY PENNSYLVANIA THE
BIRTH OF FREEDOM.
BUT IT DID.
AN ACTION NEEDED TO BE TAKEN.
THIS IS LIKE A BAD MOVIE.
EVERY DAY WE WAKE UP AND IT
STILL BEING PLAYED ON A B-ROLL.
AND IT DOES NOT HELP THE SPIRITS
PHONE THAT IS FOR SURE AND GOD
HELP THE PEOPLE TRAPPED IN
NURSING HOMES.
THEY CAN’T HAVE THEIR LOVED ONES
VISIT THEM.
THEY ARE ALONE AND MANY OF THEM
ARE DYING.
I DON’T HEAR THE LEADERS TALK
ABOUT THEM AT ALL.
WE HEARD ANDREW CUOMO SAY LIFE
IS PRECIOUS AND THIN FORCED
INFECTED PATIENTS AND THEIR
NURSING HOMES, THOUSANDS DIED
AND HE SAID PEOPLE DIED.
IT IS LIKE, DOES ANYONE CARE?
>> IT DOESN’T SEEM LIKE THAT.
THE SAD THING IS RIGHTLY
PREDICTED TO COME A LOT OF THING
THEY GOT WRONG IN THE MODELING
AND CATASTROPHIC.
WE HEARD OVER AND OVER AGAIN
FROM GOVERNOR WOLF AND SECRETARY
LEVINE, THE MOST VULNERABLE
WOULD BE THE ELDERLY WITH HEALTH
CONDITIONS.
INDEED, THAT WAS EXACTLY IT AND
THE SECRETARY OF HEALTH WITH A
MEMORANDUM WITH COVID POSITIVE
PATIENTS BACK IN ITS UTTER
MADNESS.
PENNSYLVANIA COMING OUT OF THIS.
THERE NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Tucker: TELL ME THAT
DEMOCRATS AND THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AREN’T DEFENDING THE
HEALTH DIRECTOR LIVING.
>> THEY ARE.
AND I RETIRED FROM THE ARMY TWO
YEARS AGO AND MAYBE I’M OFF MY
ROCKER BUT I THOUGHT AT SOME
POINT WE WOULD COME TOGETHER AND
AGREE WITH SHEER INCOMPETENCE
BUT NOTHING BUT MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE HERE.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE CAN DEFTLY
COME TOGETHER ALL AND CIRCLING
THE WAGONS WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION, IT IS UTTER
MADNESS.
>> HAS SHE APOLOGIZED FOR MOVING
HER OWN MOTHER OUT OF A NURSING
HOME AND THE PEOPLE STUCK THERE
TO DEATH?
>> SO OBVIOUSLY, SHE KNEW THAT
THE SECRETARY WOULD BE ASKED
THIS QUESTION LAST TUESDAY.
HAVE A PREPARED STATEMENT AND IT
WAS ACTUALLY ABSURD, RIDICULOUS
AND YOU CAN’T MAKE THIS STUFF
UP.
NO APOLOGY.
IT WOULD BE ONE THING TUCKER IF
THE SECRETARY CAME OUT TWO
MONTHS AGO AND I’M NOT SURE WE
CAN SAFEGUARD YOUR FAMILY
MEMBERS, YOUR LOVED ONES MAYBE
TAKE THEM OUT OF THE HOME FOR A
COUPLE OF MONTHS BUT INSTEAD
SPECIAL TREATMENT.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
IT WOULD BE LIKE LIQUIDATING
YOUR STOCK PORTFOLIO AND TELL
THE COUNTRY EVERYTHING WILL BE
FINE.
WE SAW THAT TOO.
IT TELLS YOU THEY DON’T CARE AT
ALL ABOUT YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SPEAKING OF THE
DANGERS AND NURSING HOME, AMY
GLYNN THE WIDOW WITH ASTRONAUT
AND FORMER SENATOR OHIO JOHN
GLENN DIED TODAY OF THE VIRUS IN
ST. PAUL, MINNESOTA.